hey guys it is the top of December my
name is Jess and it's almost too late to
buy those last-minute Christmas presents
online so you may want to get on that
well let's do me first up a massive new
dota 2 patch has arrived so pick a lane
and charge your ulti I don't know I
don't I don't know
those of you who do though this is a
pretty damn big deal
the 7.0 Update makes a bunch of changes
including adding a new character called
The Monkey King who's based on the
Chinese mythological figure Sun Wukong
he's a melee carry who slams down his
staff to stun and steal damage he can
also jump on top of an between trees
transform to disguise from enemies and
summon monkey soldiers to attack nearby
foes Bob also launched a new Monkey King
comic and will offer new Monkey King
themed items for purchase alongside the
new hero the 7.0 patch redesigns the HUD
and most significantly all characters
now have a talent trait which lets you
choose between two parks when you hit
levels 10 15 20 and 25 experience gain
gold gained and leveling up have been
altered and everybody now gets a
backpack which lets you carry three
additional items that you can swap into
your main inventory to activate as if
that wasn't enough the map has also been
updated the pregame face has been
altered rooms have been divided into two
types and there are now shrines you can
teleport to as well as the new ancient
neutral camp it actually gets even more
detailed than that so be sure to visit a
story on site for all the info next up
Microsoft have said it's still early
days for 4k and HDR gaming Xbox exec
Albert Piniella who spoke on major
Nelson's podcast about his surprise that
the ps4 slim and / consoles do not have
a 4k blu-ray drive Microsoft has made a
point of advertising the fact that the
Xbox 1s does include a 4k blu-ray drive
on the subject of 4k and HDR he added
this is the thing I like to remind
people when everybody asks we're just in
the beginning of this so games and game
developers and TV manufacturers we all
have to get used to it showing people
what 4k HDR looks like is really hard
when you're not what
- nothing in 4k or in HDR how do we
market bat and be honest you have to
fudge things a little bit to show the
differences but you want to do it in a
way that's honest finally as had been
room if more creatures did indeed
arrived in Pokemon go beginning today
you can get togepi and Pichu as well as
several other creatures from pokemon
gold and silver you can acquire these
creatures by finding eggs that pocus
dogs that can hatch into them my aunt ik
added that more Pokemon are on their way
to be at a holiday update was also
released that introduces a version of
Pikachu wearing a red and white Santa
hat if you're worried about missing out
on him Niantic says not to worry as
holiday Pikachu will appear in large
quantities probably not Zubat quantities
but still large quantities here's a
fairly cool thing to pencil in your
calendars that come Tuesday December
20th at 10 a.m. Pacific will be counting
down game spots top 5 games of the year
during a live stream so pop along for
that if you want to argue with us about
what we picked and potentially grab
yourself some prizes
that's everything we've got for you
today to do let me know what you cared
about down in that comment section and I
will see you again tomorrow